the two la deputies shot in the head are
expected to survive
one is a 31 year old mother of a young
child
the other a 24 year old man the officers
had been sitting in their car in compton
saturday night when a man or something
attempted to assassinate them
the scum is still on the loose if this
were any other type of victim not police
this would be the time that the media
would talk about climate
we've created a climate of hate and
intolerance where horrible attacks
against
this group are possible it's a climate
where certain people are hunted because
of who they are it's a climate
that fosters oppression but the victims
are police so you don't hear that even
if it's true
instead you get an embarrassment of
crickets from the media
and of course those protesters at the
hospital
jeering the victims class acts all
and of course biden calling for gun
control but after his campaign
championed paying bail of a would-be cop
killer and other
violent scum maybe he should sit this
one out
what i'd like to hear democrats bravely
saying hey you know what demonizing cops
leads nowhere good
or anchors bravely saying this is what
happens when you redefine
violence as protests first you point a
laser
then you throw a molotov and then you
kill maybe it's time to end this
i'd like to hear someone point out that
the the denial of rampant violence
and the complicit silence of leaders as
the chaos spread
made this possible maybe demonization is
demonic we don't like to hear that but
this happened to cops
so never mind how about the nfl that was
some game
did you kneel
uh dagin when i first saw on twitter it
was uh from
the police the la county sheriff's
twitter
about the protesters uh shouting that
they wanted the cops to die
and blocking the entrance of the
hospital i did not believe it in fact i
thought it had to be a hoax
and i'm still like i still i guess i
still cannot believe it i'm in denial
but it came from the the sheriff's
office
and and and there were press there
insane it leaves a lump in my throat
even hearing you
say that um and i just kept thinking
over and over
how did we get here as a nation because
it it was remember it's the it's
president
trump who was supposed to give rise to
this horrific dystopia
in the united states this dictator this
authoritarian figure
and instead it's the ant the left-wing
anti-cop movement and it didn't just
start recently i just want to mention
these two names wen jin lou
and rafael ramos right two officers
executed here in new york city by
someone who took their own life this was
back in 2014
an officer here was stabbed in the neck
in flatbush
just five officers in dallas do you
remember that right exactly
so it's the lack of pushback by the left
i will use a phrase i've heard people on
the left say
silence is accepting the unacceptable
you know what last year it was water
being thrown at cops
this year it's cement and water bottles
what's next
this kind of violence dana i
is it do do you think that there is a
link between
this kind of violent rhetoric and the
actual violence
well you know i hope that we find out
some specifics here um they
have offered a hundred thousand dollar
reward for information leading
to the perpetrator that should hopefully
pry loose some things i mean you could
imagine that there perhaps is a gang
warfare thing going on here some sort of
a dare
or maybe it's an individual that acted
alone like it's hard to say
on on that score but this is what i've
noticed
do you realize greg and you probably do
but i've noticed it
that there is not a week that has gone
by
in the last several weeks maybe three
months
that you have not done a monologue on
exactly this and you're not repeating
the same story over and over
there are new stories that have to be
tackled every single week
i don't understand the depravity of
somebody
that would jeer uh the victims at a
hospital
and you know that's where you know law
enforcement can help
but that's also something much much
deeper yeah what do you think
something that goes to the hearts yeah
what are your thoughts
uh well i you know to me this is a
despicable act right that should be
condemned by all and so far it has been
condemned by all
uh you hear president trump you hear
vice president
biden both were quick to come out and
say you can't have this kind of behavior
in a civil society it is
unacceptable it is wrong and it's crazy
it shouldn't be
shouldn't be happening i think that's
pretty clear i think what's also clear
is that president trump's campaign
and we know this because of what
kellyanne conway said long ago
tries to exploit these kind of events to
undermine
the whole notion of a racial justice
movement
of a movement towards police reform
somehow now oh it's a
you can't say that you know the reality
though is
that the president's effort at this kind
of law and order
rhetoric is not paying off and you know
the polls are pretty clear we have a
poll out today from monmouth and it says
52 percent of americans think biden
would be better
better at law and order than president
trump
and 61 say trump actually made the
protest more violent made them
worse you know you don't hear trump ever
say
you know what that guy that in kenosha
that came out there with that gun and
killed two people
he was a bad guy never hurt trump never
said a word about the uh
boogaloo boy who killed that security
guard at a federal building in oakland
never said a word
and even in los angeles it's hard for us
to stop
giving the horror of shooting these two
policemen but you got to put
it in the context which is that about
two weeks ago a young man named d
john kinsey 29 who was riding a bicycle
erratically was stopped by cops dropped
a bunch of clothes the gun was in the
close
and then he was shot to death and i
think there's been a lot of protest in
la
a lot of anger over that shooting it
doesn't justify what just took place
that's inexcusable
but that's the whole story so that's the
whole story thanks swan so now we
know that this shooting at 5 23 it only
took you a few minutes to
connect it to trump so somehow trump is
responsible for elevating
the fury of these protests somehow
leading to this
got it jesse last word i would say
juan said that it's donald trump
undermining the cause for racial justice
not the guy that shot the cops in cold
blood it's the president
for talking about the guy that shot the
cops in cold blood he's the bad guy
got it juan here's the thing the
president can't be
fanning the flames of this kind of
violence when it's the democratic party
that has over the whole summer said that
police departments are systemically
racist
and they're hunting down innocent
unarmed black people
i mean we talked about the climate it
was the same climate where the guy was a
sympathizer with a new black panther
party in dallas
sniping off white police officers the
climate
the black lives matter sympathizer
executed the nypd cops
we've seen footage footage footage all
summer
of democrats throwing rocks and bottles
of police officers
lighting their precincts on fire and
shooting lasers
and fireworks in their faces and joe
biden comes out with a statement that
says
violence of all kinds needs to be
condemned
what do you mean of all kinds joe
because i kind of got the feeling all
summer
that certain types of violence was okay
with you
right